today we're trying this vodka infused
with kale lemon peel and cucumber
apparently it might prevent asianglow
maybe asianglow is when you get really
red and hot and sad when I started
getting it I was embarrassed to because
people would think I'm really drunk when
I wasn't that drunk yet after a one-shot
I would just get read within like a few
minutes I turned beet red normally I
turn maroon like a loveseat wine color
when you go to the bathroom you look in
the mirror and you're like whoa my face
gets puffy
my whole body swells pounding headache
slurred vision whole list of side
effects that happen when I'm drunk
I'll start feeling like really heavy on
my shoulders I've never gone to hangover
the next day I get it the night of it's
gotten worse as I've gotten older my
experience with alcohol is my experience
with asianglow you can't separate the
two I looked it up and they said you can
take pasta to prevent it so I started
doing dog 90% of time at work I actually
have a bottle of tested in my car and my
dust at home in the night stand with
pepcid you get slightly pink but not
like crazy red my regiment Suzanne
attacks and then I take a Claridon and
then I'll get like a burger I'm armed
with eyedrops if I do it properly then
I'd like we'll have nothing I used to do
that and then I just got tired of
bringing pills it's kind of weird I just
pop take his pills before I I really
start departing and it'd be amazing if I
don't have to take pops it every time
before I was at an event ask the person
behind the bar if I could get the
tiniest bit of alcohol she said I might
not get an allergic reaction with this
vodka and I was skeptical of it the next
day I wear it messaged all the Asian
people and was like I found this drink
that my prevent Asian glow and we're
like what the heck and we were all
excited to try it to see if this can
actually work cause it would be a
game-changer for Asian people we do want
to say that vodka wasn't made for Asian
glue Maggie just happened to find it
we're kind of just testing it on our
home
it smells fruity to me it's not lemony
healthy juice and veggies does smell
like kale
really let's kill smell hail smells like
hail let's do this no blow
it's a really nice lemony aftertaste
like a lapper gave out of mine I know
like an Willy Wonka it was like the gum
daniel's and then you become a blueberry
it's kind of like that but for a salad
oh god Nicky I found out that the
alcohol doesn't have histamines in it
it's super distilled usually pepcid as a
histamine blocker and we think that that
might be why I might not get agent glow
from it water mixed with lemon and a
shot they don't taste this alcohol at
all I don't taste it either really
refreshing super clean let's just say
it's like lemon juice to me it tastes
like one of those shots you get it like
a juice bar like a health shot tastes
great so I don't need the extra sugar
great if you're trans he was a couple
pounds my face is very hot and I should
I feeling the heat right now though I'm
sorry I'm starting to really feel this
up yeah how many minutes this is Ben are
the cameras really yeah oh this vodka
I've noticed that one shot is actually
pretty strong yeah is it weird that my
burps taste good in the past year I
maybe had a sip of other people's
strength and never my own it's expensive
rather buy pasta normally I would get
red it starts here and then it just like
slowly transitions down to my like neck
and shoulders it's like mystique and
x-men sober Maggie Maggie back in the
day and water was dirty
Europeans drank alcohol and Asian
strength tea they built up a tolerance
to it and we didn't so we can drink
loads of tea drink normal tea like
lacking M's and NZ like an enzyme say we
can't process dairy and can't process
alcohol it's great right where's my
enzyme white I'm a little white I'm 1/8
white I'm more white than you right now
instead of asianglow just looks like you
ran away like I'm very athletic I feel
great I do feel a little bit buzzy and
one shot of vodka would not make me
buzzy you're just nodding your head like
you're cuz I'm wasted right now do you
feel my face
getting read as nice I feel simply
someone should do I feel like I live a
very full life without this feeling all
right so right now we're about to check
tough you can so look at how red we are
compared to normal
oh wow you look well shiny I'm not sure
I really thought this was not gonna make
me bad usually I'm a lot redder this
looks good like I look like a white
blush like on purpose this does not work
for me I feel like I do every time I
drink I'm only like slightly pink
usually I get so right as pink as I
would if I took Pepsi and I need to
drink this more often yeah no this is
nothing this is like me just doing a few
situps
this is probably how I normally turn
when I take a pepcid so without taking
pepcid and added chemical just having
the alcohol this is great pink here it's
actually super mild right now yeah I
don't know like I can't really tell it
boys are you really yeah I totally
recommend the Karaka I feel amazing I
love the taste I would drink this again
this is my new go-to drink I just want
to take a nap I just long right now I
feel great I want to hug everybody in
this room I feel super I don't feel like
I'm dying I don't feel like I need a
sleep I don't think the preventing
asianglow worked on me so I don't think
that I would go out of my way to like
buy a bottle of magic Asian luck and
I've just been sipping on it like over
in the corner so like I guess I would
drink it again I feel like I do every
time I drink and I think I look this way
too
I for sure would try this again usually
I'll take one shot and feel like I'm
gonna throw up everywhere but I feel
really good I'll put it in the flash
take it with me wherever so this is the
end of our test it's not super
scientific out of eight people that we
tested today eight out of five worked G
five out of eight worked you can't have
to try it for yourself we don't know we
have no idea we're not scientist we
don't know why or how we are just
regular people I think it's the
histamines right I'm totally on board
for this I just want to dance do you
want to dance I want to be here we
should dance there's a sound system at
the end of the day
yes I personally would try it again yeah
and maybe for the people that it doesn't
work on hopefully there's something else
that will work for you exactly
[Music]